well following the russian withdrawal
from northern ukraine we've seen video
from inside the town of butcher i'm
joined by our defense and security
analyst professor michael clark who is
going to analyze some of this footage
and a warning that we will be looking at
footage that some may find distressing
and this is basically first of all
satellite imagery is it yeah well
there's some other stuff mark first of
all there's a famous video that's been
running for a few days this is jablonski
street in butcher
and it shows the vehicles ukrainian
vehicles having to drive round to slalom
round bodies in the road we've pixard
them pixel them out um so that they're
not so horrible but there's this this
vehicle
recording bodies having to drive around
them the russians have said this is
simply not true
these bodies have appeared since they
left the area on the 30th 31st of march
and they said these bodies were just
placed there um obviously by the
ukrainians in order to discredit the
russians and so this piece of film is
has been subject to an enormous amount
of controversy but maxar who are the
private american organization that deal
with satellite imagery this is exactly
the same this is jablonska street
exactly the same process and what appear
to be the same bodies the same shadow
the bodies exactly next to the same
things they were next to on the previous
video it's been very carefully organized
very carefully um analyzed and
forensically looked at and the fact is
all of these apparent bodies um have
been there since the 19th of march we
know this image is the 19th of march
when the russians say they couldn't have
been there uh up to the 30th
untrue untrue so that's i think fairly
clear evidence of out there forensic
work being done by the the open source
intelligence community is actually
giving the lie to some of these russian
claims
and then we can look at another piece of
footage which has come in
recently everyone's getting very excited
about this and it is pretty the whole
thing i have to say we've looked at a
few times it's pretty gruesome there's a
group of of russian tanks coming down
the road there's a couple of um
infantry fighting vehicles who are
actually looking after those tanks as
you would expect them to
and this poor cyclist who is moving up
the road gets off their bike moves
around the corner we don't know if the
cyclist is a man or a woman and one of
the infantry fighting vehicles fires a
shot
dust comes up here as we can see
and in that spot later on there is a
dead cyclist and a great deal of carnage
around it
we don't know for certain if that is the
person that was shot by that shot from
the infantry fighting vehicle but
then this is a long piece of film uh
we've all looked at it a lot and we've
edited it right down to those particular
those particular bits but there's a lot
of this around at the moment but prima
facie evidence of
possible war crime but
people investigating this now just so
difficult to do isn't it for sure
there's so much ambiguity it looks clear
when you look at the whole thing what's
happened but actually you don't know did
the russians um if they fired were they
firing at this person or were they
firing at somebody else and
this person got in the way did they have
a legitimate target did they think that
this person might have been a terrorist
with a suicide belt coming to threaten
them did they fire accidentally i mean
if i was a if i was a russian
solicitor i would actually make all of
these arguments because even a piece of
film is as apparently obvious as that
apparently obvious as that is full of
ambiguities so is that a war crime very
hard to prove but it is the sort of
event that happens 100 times a day
in situations like this but on the other
hand and just finally you know the
amount of coverage in terms of satellite
imagery and phones and this will help
the war crimes investigations never in
history has a war been forensically
examined from the very beginning by the
global community as this one this is
unique in history it's never happened
before usually this sort of thing is is
an afterthought this time it's happening
day by day by day there will be millions
of images like this by the end of this
miserable process and a lot of evidence
thank you very much indeed
so what happens now what impact will the
images from ukraine have on the course
of the war in ukraine well on thursday
i'll be speaking to one of vladimir
putin's closest advisors his press
secretary dmitry peskov
watch the view from the kremlin putin
spokesman live at 5 pm on thursday here
on
sky news